[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers hallo
und guten Abend ihnen allen russlands
Präsident verkündet heute es gäbe keinen
Plan keinen Grund den Plan zu ändern für
die spezialoperation wie er seinen Krieg
gegen die Ukraine nennt und gleichzeitig
werden Briefe bekannt die russische
Soldaten offenbar bei ihrem ungeordneten
Rückzug aus der ukrainischen Stadt ist
zurückgelassen haben in denen sie
verzweifelt um Entlassung bitten aus der
Armee
was in Ischium auch zurückbleibt und
jetzt nach und nach ans Licht kommt ist
eine weitere Nachricht bei der man den
Atem anhält
450 Gräber jetzt muss geklärt werden ob
die Toten darin Opfer von
Kriegsverbrechen wurden Katrin Eugendorf
es liegt ein beißender Gestank über dem
kiefernhain am Rande von isium ein
Gestank nach Tod und Verwesung über 450
Menschen davon gehen die Ermittler aus
liegen in der sandigen Erde verscharrt
und müssen jetzt geborgen werden immer
wieder müssen die Ermittler Pause machen
viele wirken schockiert traurig und
sprachlos
an diesem Ort arbeiten zehn
Ermittlungsteams bislang haben wir zehn
Gräber geöffnet und haben die
körpertoter Zivilisten herausgenommen
sie werden von den Experten untersucht
Experiment die meisten namenlosen
nummerierten Holzkreuze die sich über
die Lichtung ziehen ein Bild das um die
Welt geht ein Symbol für neue
Kriegsverbrechen sogar schlimmer als
Butcher der ukrainische Präsident wurde
mir selenski zieht Vergleiche
haben wir heute 450 Leichen gefunden
aber es gibt noch weitere einzelne
Gräber mit toten gefolterte Menschen in
einigen Gebieten sogar ganze
Familienzimmer
die gerade erst befreite Stadt im Osten
der Ukraine liegt weitgehend in Trümmern
nach mehr als sechs Monaten unter
russischer Besatzung wissen viele nicht
einmal wo ihre toten Angehörigen und
Freunde sind dass die Russen Ukrainern
den Befehl gaben Tote zu begraben
erzählen die Einwohner
sie wurden begraben dann haben sie
Nummern darauf geschrieben mit diesen
Nummern konnte man herausfinden wer es
war
Grube für Grube die die Ermittler
ausheben entdecken Sie weitere Leichen
viele bereits kaum noch identifizieren
in Plastiksäcken werden sie in Kühlwagen
nach hakif gebracht zur genaueren
Untersuchung das alles präzise
dokumentiert wird ist der Regierung
wichtig und noch eins dass die Welt so
schnell wie möglich von den Funden
erfährt deswegen hat die Polizei heute
Medien aus aller Welt nach isum gebracht
Katrin du warst heute mit dabei in Issum
wie lange wird es denn dauern bis die
Welt auch mehr Klarheit darüber bekommt
was dort geschehen ist wie die Menschen
ums Leben gekommen sind
die Ermittlungen stehen noch ganz am
Anfang und gestalten sich sehr schwierig
auf der einen Seite ist es ja ein Gebiet
was teilweise noch vermiet ist also wir
haben da auch erlebt wie Minensucher
unterwegs waren wir konnten auch nur auf
bestimmten Wegen gehen es ist sehr
gefährlich sich dazu bewegen und auf der
anderen Seite dauert es sehr lange bis
all die Gräber geöffnet sind also die
Ermittler gehen davon aus dass es noch
mindestens eine Woche dauern wird
überhaupt all die Leichnamen die sie
dort vermuten oder von denen sie Listen
haben aus dem Boden zu holen dann müssen
die ja noch mal untersucht werden dann
müssen auch Zeugen vernommen werden also
bis man einen genaues umfassendes Bild
hat werden denke ich mal mindestens noch
zwei Wochen vergehen und das ist der
ukrainische Regierung entsprechend
wichtig das genau aufzuklären und was
auch wichtig ist dass hier auch
internationale Experten zur Rate gezogen
werden und irgendwann in dieses Gebiet
kommen das wird allerdings erst dann
möglich sein wenn das einigermaß sicher
ist man sieht die Bilder du hast es auch
gerade im Beitrag angesprochen man denkt
natürlich erstmal an Botschaft wo du ja
auch gewesen bist inwieweit kann man
denn die beiden Orte und was dort
geschah vergleichen oder eben auch nicht
vergleichen
also man kann sie in einer Hinsicht
sicherlich nicht vergleichen in den
Orten die hier befreit wurden hat die
Bevölkerung über ein halbes Jahr unter
russischer Besatzung gelebt das heißt da
hat es auch eine gewisse ein gewisses
System gegeben was die Russen da
eingerichtet haben ich habe das ja im
Beitrag erzählt sie haben im Prinzip
Ukrainer ukrainische Bevölkerung dazu
gezwungen Leichen von den Straßen oder
auch aus getroffenen Gebäuden
wegzutransportieren und dort zu
beerdigen das war in Butcher nicht der
Fall da hat man Leute einfach in ja
Gräber reingeworfen da waren die
Soldaten ja auch wesentlich kürzer dann
was die Identifikation der Menschen dort
angeht die haben ja viel viel länger in
diesen Gräbern gelegen das heißt das ist
gar nicht mehr so schnell feststellbar
um wen es sich da handelt also die
Aufklärungsarbeit wird dort sicherlich
auch viel komplizierter sein was den
Umfang der vermeintlichen
Kriegsverbrechen angeht ist es
sicherlich mit Butcher zu vergleichen
wenn silenski hat ja auch gesagt es ist
zweimal Butcher aber man muss natürlich
auch vorsichtig sein dass man sich da so
bestimmten Slogans nicht anschließt ja
die die Regierung in Kiew hier
verbreitet sondern man muss abwarten was
kommt wirklich bei den Ermittlungen raus
und wie umfangreich ist das und was ist
davon auch wirklich ein Kriegsverbrechen
Kathrin Eigendorf live in der Ukraine
herzlichen Dank
ja was kann was sollte was muss
Deutschland tun die Debatte um
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine ist
fast so alt wie dieser Krieg viele
Forderungen auf der einen Seite viel
Vorsicht auf der anderen jetzt kommt
neue Bewegung in diese Debatte und es
zeigen sich auffällige Unterschiede auch
innerhalb der Bundesregierung mattes
feldhofft mit mir dazu
es liegt in diesen Tagen eine besondere
Erwartungshaltung in der Luft wenn der
Bundeskanzler über Sicherheitspolitik
spricht heute vor der Generalität der
Bundeswehr kommt sie die überraschende
Ankündigung die Kehrtwende die große
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern nach Kiew um
es vorwegzunehmen diese Ankündigung kam
nicht
er hätte diese Ankündigung gern gehört
der ukrainische Parlamentspräsident
Russland stefancuk zeitgleich zur
sicherheitspolitischen Grundsatz Rede
des Kanzlers war er Gast der
Bundestagspräsidentin
die Situation an der Front hat sich
verändert so Stefan tschuck dank unserer
Armee aber auch dank der Waffen die wir
jetzt bekommen haben wir nutzen diese
modernen Waffen sehr effizient und
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt auch neue
Waffen
Olaf Scholz kennt diese Forderung und
gibt ihr scheibchenweise nach
gestern hatte er seine
Verteidigungsministerin überraschend
ankündigen lassen dass man jetzt 50
gepanzerte Transportfahrzeuge vom Typ
Dingo an die Ukraine übergibt außerdem
zwei weitere Raketenwerfer Mars 2 mit
200 Raketen
die Lieferung von schweren modernen
westlichen Panzern lehnt Scholz weiter
ab
das was wir machen auch in der
Unterstützung der Ukraine ist ja sehr
entschieden aber auch immer
besonnen doch manchem Regierungsmitglied
geht das besonnene inzwischen schwer
gegen den Strich in einem Gespräch im
Kanzleramt am Dienstag soll die
Außenministerin Olaf Scholz zu einer
schnellen Entscheidung in Sachen Panzer
gedrängt haben um es dann zwei Tage
später öffentlich zu sagen in der
entscheidenden Phase in der sich die
Ukraine gerade befindet halte ich das
nicht für eine Entscheidung die lange
hinausgezögert werden sollte so Werbung
in der FAZ Stefan Schuck hat heute den
G7 eine neue Liste mit militärischen
wünschen übergeben eine Liste die
zumindest in den Parlamenten vielfach
auf Verständnis stößt Putin führt ein
Kampf gegen alle liberalen Demokratien
im des Westens und der ruiniert dabei
sein eigenes Land so war moralisch
wirtschaftlich als auch politisch
und diesen Kampf wird er nicht gewinnen
am Abend dann ein neues Scheibchen in
der Entwicklung das
Verteidigungsministerium gibt bekannt
dass im sogenannten Ringtausch 40
Schützenpanzer bmp1 aus Griechenland an
die Ukraine geliefert werden Deutschland
liefert im Gegenzug dafür auch
Schützenpanzer vom Typ Marder allerdings
nach Athen
es kommt ziemlich selten vor dass der
Bundeskanzler auf einer
Betriebsversammlung auftaucht heute
Abend ist Olaf Scholz bei den
Beschäftigten der PCK Raffinerie in
Schwedt denn die steht seit heute unter
Kontrolle des Staates sie gilt als
lebenswichtig für den Osten Deutschlands
90 Prozent der Versorgung mit Benzin und
Heizöl für Berlin und Brandenburg kommen
von PCK und sie war bislang wie so
vieles was für Deutschlands
Energiesicherheit essentiell ist
mehrheitlich in russischer Hand die
dunklen Schatten und verheerenden
Fehleinschätzungen der Vergangenheit
holen uns erneut ein denn erstens wird
die Staatsverwaltung der deutschen
Rosneft Firmen sehr teuer und zweitens
ist nicht klar wie sicher der
vollständige Weiterbetrieb der
Raffinerien jetzt tatsächlich ist David
Gebhardt mit mehr dazu
die Flamme der Ölraffinerie PCK Schwedt
brennt über der Stadt und die Stadt
brennt für die PCK Herzkammer
Arbeitgeber identitätsstifterin und so
verbreitet sich heute die Nachricht von
der Übernahme des mehrheitseigners
rosnew durch den Bund wie ein Lauffeuer
auf dem Marktplatz das hauptsache es
geht weiter
es kann ja nicht sein dass die ganze
Region hier stirbt er soll
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleistet sein
aber ich redet noch nicht so ich kann
mir vorstelle gut sehr viele Engpässe
hier zu unseren Politikern Vertrauen
habe ich da nichts mehr die Vorbehalte
sind groß gegenüber denen in Berlin und
stehen irgendwie auch stellvertretend
für eine Stimmung die sich in Teilen
Deutschlands zu drehen droht wohl auch
deshalb heute großer Bahnhof im
Kanzleramt Scholz Habeck voitcke zu
dritt vor der Presse die Botschaft wir
kümmern uns
das ist eine weitreichende
energiepolitische Entscheidung zum
Schutz unseres Landes und mit der
Treuhand und den Entscheidung die wir
hier miteinander vorbereitet haben ist
auch gesichert dass kein Arbeitnehmer in
Schwedt Angst um seinen Arbeitsplatz
haben muss zur Sicherung 3er Raffinerien
unter anderem in Schwedt setzt die
Bundesregierung auf eine treuhandlösung
stellt die Mehrheitseigner zwei rosnews
Tochterfirmen für sechs Monate unter
Kontrolle der Bundesnetzagentur und
damit des Wirtschaftsministeriums
weil wir gesehen haben dass sich
Versicherer Dienstleister
IT-Dienstleister aber auch Abnehmer
immer stärker zurückgezogen haben und
die Region durch die wichtige Raffinerie
Schwedt in eine Situation hätte geraten
können wo die Versorgungssicherheit
nicht mehr gegeben ist allein für Berlin
und Brandenburg deckt Schwedt 95% des
Treibstoff und heizölbedarfs und steht
jetzt vor gewaltigen Herausforderungen
wenn das Öl embargo ab Januar greift und
spätestens dann kein Öl mehr durch die
mehrere tausend Kilometer lange
truschbar Pipeline aus Sibirien Russland
kommt unter anderem eine Röhre ab dem
Hafen Rostock soll für Ersatz sorgen
doch das bringt Probleme
die Pipeline von der Ostsee nach
schwedte reicht noch nicht aus um die
Raffinerie vollständig mit Öl zu
versorgen das Problem muss jetzt
dringend angegangen werden wir brauchen
zweitens die Öltanker die es auch in die
seichte Ostsee schaffen und drittens
muss sie Raffinerie so umgebaut werden
dass sie auch andere Rohölsorten
außerdem aus Russland verarbeiten kann
im Rahmen eines sogenannten
zukunftspaket soll nun etwa eine
Milliarde Euro investiert werden um die
Transformation zu schaffen
man hätte diese bittere Pille eine
Milliarde Steuergeld ersparen können
wenn wir auf die Warnung und der letzten
15 Jahre mehr gehört hätten dass wir
nicht zu abhängig sind von russischen
Energielieferung insbesondere Öl das hat
man leider in dem Wind geschlagen um zu
verhindern dass die Belegschaft in
Schwedt auf die Barrikaden ging
kletterte Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
schon mal auf einen Tisch heute taucht
hier am Abend überraschend der Kanzler
auf und der Ministerpräsident
Brandenburgs um in Schwedt die Wogen bei
den Betroffenen zu glätten
ja und der Ministerpräsident
Brandenburgs Dietmar wotke von der SPD
ist jetzt live aus Schwedt hier bei uns
im heute-journal Herr Ministerpräsident
schönen guten Abend
schönen Abend sie in Brandenburg auch
die Berlinerinnen und Berliner hängen
komplett am Tropf dieser Raffinerie
jetzt haben sie ganz offensichtlich ja
die Geduld verloren mit dem Management
weil es auf russisches Öl eben nicht
verzichten wird als eine Firma die
mehrheitlichen russischer Hand ist aber
wie läuft denn das jetzt konkreter wo
wollt wir werden da jetzt erstmal alle
Entscheider ausgewechselt in dem
Unternehmen
also das sind Entscheidungen die der
Bund zu treffen hat das steht ja unter
Treuhand des Bundes die
treuhandfunktion wird ausgeübt über die
Bundesnetzagentur also das sind
Entscheidungen die der Bund zu treffen
hat welche Manager an welcher Stelle
eingesetzt werden wer diese
Managementaufgaben in Zukunft erfüllt
aber wie können sie denn dann die
Garantie geben die sie heute abgegeben
haben oder abgeben wollten zumindest
nämlich dass die Versorgungssicherheit
jetzt mit dem heutigen Tag gewährleistet
sei
also die Garantie der
Versorgungssicherheit kann das Land
Brandenburg ohnehin nicht abgeben weil
die Versorgungssicherheit natürlich
durch den Bund hier in im Fokus stehen
muss der Bund muss dafür sorgen dass es
zusätzliche Öllieferungen gibt da sind
Vorkehrungen getroffen das hat uns das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium mehrfach
erklärt und die sind auch notwendig
damit hier dieser Affinerie weiterläuft
sie ist ja sie haben sehr deutlich
dargestellt auch in dem Vorbericht sie
ist schon
systemrelevant für die Ölversorgung in
ganz Deutschland und wenn immer nur
gesagt wird Brandenburg und Berlin denn
verniedlich das glaube ich hier die
Rolle die diese Raffinerie für ganz
Deutschland spielt gut für Brandenburg
und Berlin natürlich noch mal ganz
besonders was machen Sie denn sollte
Russland jetzt wiederum auf die heutige
Entwicklung so reagieren und sagen wir
schicken gar kein Öl mehr nach Schwedt
durch diese druckbar Pipeline
das ist durch die Bundesregierung
vorbereitet worden also da sind
entsprechende Vorkehrungen getroffen das
hat der Kanzler hier wir haben ja gerade
eine Betriebsversammlung gehabt auch
noch mal dargelegt da sind also die
ganzen Geschichten wurden ja über Monate
über viele Monate vorbereitet es wurden
Gespräche geführt mit verschiedenen
Partnern die auch die Öllieferung
garantieren können es ist heute übrigens
auch das was ausgeführt worden ist
vorhin nicht ganz korrekt also ich
glaube das war Frau Kämpfer die gesagt
hat eine Milliarde hätte man sich sparen
können wenn man zeitiger auf russisches
Öl verzichtet hätte wenn Sie sich genau
angucken wofür das Geld eingesetzt wird
dann geht es hier um die klimaneutrale
Transformation es geht darum erneuerbare
Energien aus der Uckermark in Zukunft in
eine klimaneutraler Raffinerie zu
bringen und diese Produkte
klimaneutrales Kerosin beispielsweise
dann in Deutschland
anwendbar zu machen und verfügbar zu
machen und deswegen geht es hier um viel
viel mehr auch mit diesem Geld geht es
um die Zukunft dieser Raffinerie und
nicht am Festhalten an irgendwelchen
Ölsorten aus irgendwelchen Ländern
können Sie uns das noch mal genauer
erklären wie das funktionieren soll das
ausgerechnet eine Ölraffinerie
klimaneutral werden soll
das funktioniert indem man
beispielsweise über die Zwischenstufe
Wasserstoff aus
erneuerbarer Energie die Uckermark ist
eine der Regionen in Deutschland mit der
höchsten Menge an erzeugter erneuerbare
Energie aus über diese Zwischenstufe
Wasserstoff zum Beispiel synthetisches
Kerosin
sustainable aviation fuel SAF abgekürzt
produziert das wird nachgefragt heute
schon bei einer ganzen Reihe von
Airlines die unbedingt klimaneutraler
fliegen wollen in Zukunft auch durch
EU-Regeln klimaneutraler fliegen müssen
also das sind Investitionen die hier
laufen Investitionen in die Zukunft und
das hier die Fachkräfte vor Ort gehalten
werden müssen versteht sich dann von
selbst also hier übernimmt der Bund
Verantwortung auch für die Beschäftigten
das ist vollkommen richtig weil ohne
diese Beschäftigten hat der Standort
auch mit Klimaneutralität keine Zukunft
jetzt ist diese Treuhandverwaltung
allerdings erstmal auf sechs Monate
befristet was passiert denn danach
das wird sich in den nächsten Monaten
zeigen dass ist jetzt erstmal eine Zahl
von Monaten die
ausgewählt worden ist um die Dinge zu
regeln ich gehe davon aus dass wird eine
längere Zeit sein wo der Bund hier
Verantwortung übernimmt und dann wird es
gegebenenfalls zu einer Enteignung
kommen das wird man dann prüfen müssen
aber das sind juristische Prüfungen die
auf der Bundesebene laufen nicht beim
Land Brandenburg
Herr Wolfgang ihr Kollege Kretschmer
Ministerpräsident in Sachsen direkt
nebenan der sagt heute das ganze ist
eine Fehlentscheidung Bürger und
Unternehmen sagt er werden das teuer
bezahlen zumindest wenn man die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler nimmt
da hat er recht oder
ich gehe davon aus dass die Entscheidung
heute die richtige Entscheidung war sie
ist lange vorbereitet gewesen sie
eröffnet diesem standortperspektiven das
heißt jetzt kann hier investiert werden
beispielsweise das was ich vorhin schon
geschildert habe in klimaneutrale
Produktion mit der erneuerbaren Energie
die hier vor der Haustür steht wenn sie
herfahren in die Raffinerie dann fahren
sie ungefähr an ich weiß nicht vier oder
500 Windkraftanlagen vorbei und das kann
damit auch ein Modell werden für ganz
Deutschland wenn wir wirklich
Transformation ernst meinen beweisen wir
es jetzt hier in der Uckermark beweisen
wir es in Schwedt und das kann wirklich
ein Modell sein für viele andere
Industriebetriebe auch in Deutschland
und so sollten wir das ganze auch sehen
und dass die Menschen hier Sicherheit
verdienen und nicht die dummen sein
dürfen die dann unter den Entscheidungen
zu leiden haben die in Diktator im Kreml
trifft ich glaube auch das versteht sich
von selbst und hier übernimmt die
Bundesregierung Verantwortung
was sagt der Ministerpräsident von
Brandenburg Dietmar woltke live aus
Schwedt an der Oder Herr Wolf gehabt
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch heute
Abend bei uns
ich danke Ihnen alles Gute alles Gute
ihnen und ein Gespräch mit einem
Energieexperten zum Thema nachher im
heute journal Update mit Gundula Gause
jetzt aber erstmal weitere Themen im
Überblick und den Überblick und den hast
du Hannah ganz genau der Bundesrat hat
heute den
zweitbesitzerinnen und Besitzer einer
Gasheizung da die Anlagen oft
ineffizient arbeiten müssen Sie ab dem 1
Oktober überprüft und gegebenenfalls
optimiert werden und das innerhalb von
zwei Jahren
gaszentralheizungen in größeren Gebäuden
müssen hydraulisch abgeglichen und
technisch veraltete Heizungspumpen
ausgetauscht werden
die NATO führt derzeit ein
großangelegtes Manöver ihrer schnellen
Eingreiftruppe durch und zwar im
östlichen Mittelmeer es wird von der
türkischen Marine geführt und umfasst
etwa 8.500 Soldaten aus 13 Ländern geübt
wird die Abwehr eines Angriffs auf ein
Mitgliedsland dabei geht es laut NATO
vor allem darum die Einsatzbereitschaft
und Zusammenarbeit der multinationalen
Krisenreaktionskräfte zu verbessern
der deutsche Apothekerverband waren das
Medikamente in Deutschland immer
häufiger nicht lieferbar sein aktuell
würde dies mehr als 250 Mittel betreffen
erklärte der stellvertretende
Vorsitzende Hubmann darunter gängige
Medikamente gegen Bluthochdruck und
Diabetes in den vergangenen Monaten war
außerdem ein wichtiges brustkrebs-
in Italien sind bei schweren Unwettern
und Überschwemmungen mindestens zehn
Menschen ums Leben gekommen vier weitere
gelten als vermisst in der Nacht viel in
Ancona und Umgebung innerhalb weniger
Stunden so viel Regen wie sonst in sechs
Monaten Straßen und Häuser wurden
überflutet Regierungschef Draghi
kündigte einen Besuch der Region und
Hilfsgelder in Höhe von 5 Millionen Euro
an
wir wissen nicht wie sich die
corona-pandemie im Herbst und Winter
entwickeln wird auch der
Bundesgesundheitsminister weist das
nicht wir wissen jetzt aber wie das neue
Infektionsschutzgesetz aussieht dem
haben heute auch die Länder via
Bundesrat zugestimmt nur ob damit viel
gewonnen ist wissen wir wiederum nicht
das neue Gesetz steckt voller
Kompromisse und Widersprüche und dessen
Kern nämlich ein tagesaktuelles Bild der
Lage in den Krankenhäusern zu bekommen
sei technisch gar nicht umsetzbar warnen
heute bereits die Krankenhäuser
Deutschland und sein ganz eigener Umgang
mit Corona Britta Spiekermann
die Reise in den Herbst steckt voller
Widersprüche in Fernzügen wird die
maskenpflicht verschärft den Flugzeugen
können dagegen die Masken ab Anfang
Oktober fallen das sorgt für Zweifel
auch bei denen die am Ende dafür stimmen
werden
man kann sicherlich darauf hinweisen
dass es unterschiedliche Lüftungssysteme
gibt aber dennoch ich teile natürlich
auch den Eindruck dass es besser und
klarer wäre wenn wir im Fernverkehr
insgesamt eine Regelung hätten die dann
gleichermaßen gelten würde es ist nicht
der einzige Widerspruch heute im
Bundesrat das Infektionsschutzgesetz ein
mit der FDP schwer ausgehandelter
Kompromiss breiter Widerstand die Regeln
seien zu unklar Schulen benachteiligt
die einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht gar
kontraproduktiv dicke Luft in der
Länderkammer
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
und da lieber Karl Lauterbach meine
Bitte die einrichtungsbezogene
impfanordnung muss jetzt aus aufgehoben
werden weil sie immer mehr Unfrieden in
die Einrichtung trägt und nicht zu mehr
Stabilität und schon gar nicht zu mehr
Solidarität führt ich kann diesem Gesetz
meine Zustimmung nicht geben Karl
Lauterbach der eiserne zunehmend einsame
Verfechter möglichst strenger
corona-regeln in Europa hat er damit
inzwischen ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal
Lauterbach mahnt und erntet Widerspruch
ich möchte nicht dass wir uns daran
gewöhnen dass jeden Tag
150 oder gar 200 Menschen in Zukunft
jeden Tag an sarskow sterben und zum
Teil schwer sterben das ist nicht der
Tod den man sich selbst oder seinen
geliebten Menschen wünscht wir sehen
kaum mehr schwer kranke in der
sichtpatienten wir sehen kaum mehr
Todesfälle das ist sehr sehr positiv zu
bewerten wir haben gute Medikamente wir
bekommen immer bessere Impfstoffe also
da hat ein dramatischer eine dramatische
wen ich jetzt abgezeichnet und
stattgefunden das Kapitel Schulen
ursprünglich wollte die Regierung eine
testpflicht für Kinder bei
corona-verdacht bevor sie wieder in die
Schule gehen auf den letzten Metern
kippen die Länder diese Regel was in
Zukunft gilt bleibt rätselhaft auch die
maskenpflicht für Heimbewohnerinnen und
Bewohner sorgt für ernsthafte Bedenken
im dritten Jahr der Pandemie schließlich
sei fast jeder mehrfach geimpft die
Maske eine schwere Last der Schutz
wollen rablergruppen ist wichtig aber er
muss auch mit dem Selbstbestimmungsrecht
dieser Menschen einhergehen und gerade
demenzkranke Menschen benötigen das den
Ausdruck die Mimik des Gegenübers und
das geht ihnen wieder für ein weiteres
halbes Jahr verloren es ist ein Gesetz
voller Widersprüche zum Schluss noch ein
weiterer wesentlicher eigentlich sollten
Krankenhäuser künftig Daten an
Gesundheitsämter übermitteln nicht
umsetzbar heißt es jetzt von den
Kliniken auch sein herberrückschlag für
Lauterbach der eine
wissenschaftsbasierte Politik bei
Amtsantritt versprochen hat
und jetzt hier nochmal Hannah mit noch
mal Wirtschaft
eigentlich wollte der Autobauer Opel
bald nach China expandieren und dort
Elektroautos verkaufen doch heute wird
bekannt diese Pläne liegen auf Eis
Hintergrund sollen laut Medienberichten
auch die geopolitische Gesamtlage und
Chinas Null covet-politik sein Frank
Bethmann ist das jetzt ein Einzelfall
oder ein Beispiel für einen generelles
Umdenken in der Wirtschaft was China
betrifft in den Vorstandsetagen fängt
schon ein Umdenken an wenn auch erst
langsam die Risiken der einseitigen
Energieabhängigkeit von Russland bringt
viele Manager zumindest ins Grübeln doch
wie schwer das umorientieren fällt dafür
stellvertretend für viele andere die
Aussage von Chef der BASF Martin
brudermüller der kürzlich das China
Engagement seines Konzerns verteidigte
China ist der am stärksten wachsende
chemiemarkt und wird 2030 die Hälfte des
Weltmarktes ausmachen es ist schwierig
zu sagen man nehme daran nicht teil zu
sehen ist auch die deutschen Autobauer
ihre Abhängigkeit abzulesen an den
Absatzzahlen VW verkauft inzwischen
nahezu jedes zweite Auto in der
Volksrepublik Mercedes und BMW setzen
mit jeweils über 30% jedes dritte
Fahrzeug in China ab ganz anders Opel
das angekündigte China Comeback bereits
wieder einkassiert der Rückzieher jetzt
möglicherweise noch zur rechten Zeit
denn das China Geschäft ist sehr viel
riskanter geworden was nicht zuletzt an
den geopolitischen Verwerfungen liegt
doch auch ohne diese wäre es für die
Rüsselsheimer schwer geworden der Markt
hart umkämpft über 120 Automarken dort
vertreten niemand so Fachleute würde auf
Opel im Reich der Mitte warten vielen
Dank nach Frankfurt
und noch kurz zum Fußball das
freitagabendspiel in der ersten Liga
ging gerade zu Ende FSV Mainz gegen
Hertha BSC 1 zu 1
er gehörte zu den prägenden Figuren des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks der
Journalist Fritz Pleitgen ist gestern
Abend im Alter von 84 Jahren gestorben
Abschied lange Zeit war Pleitgen
Korrespondent für die ARD berichtete aus
Moskau oder Washington aber auch von
historischen Ereignissen wie dem sechs
Tage Krieg in Ägypten oder dem Mauerfall
in Berlin zurück nach Köln berufen wurde
er Chefredakteur im WDR und war dann ab
1995 12 Jahre lang Intendant des Senders
in seiner Zeit in Köln moderierte
Pleitgen zudem den ARD Presseclub
Trenchcoat Mikrofon roter Platz Fritz
Pleitgen war und bleibt eine Ikone
gerade der Auslandsberichterstattung im
Herzen immer Reporter
das war unsere Welt dann diesem Freitag
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen einen schönen
Abend noch tschüss
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter heute
Abend ja diese schlimmen Unwetter
gestern und auch heute noch über Italien
bekamen ihre Energie und ihre feuchte
aus dem viel zu warmen Meerwasser des
Mittelmeers wir sehen das hier rundum
Italien ist das Wasser so drei vier Grad
wärmer als normal übrigens auch die Ost-
und die Nordsee und dann bekommen Stürme
und Gewitter noch mehr Energie und das
gibt übrigens auch einen Ausblick für
den Herbst und um das Mittelmeer und
diese hohen Wassertemperaturen kommen
durch diesen Rekord heißen Sommer in
Europa zustande den uns die Klimakrise
beschert hat und was dann noch passiert
ist ist im Grunde genau das gleiche wie
bei uns zwischen diesem Tief und diesem
hoch kam die kalte Luft aus dem Norden
und prallte dann auf die warmen
Temperaturen des Mittelmeers bei uns
löst das ganze nur in Anführungszeichen
Schauer und Gewitter aus die auch heute
Nacht von der Nordsee ins Land ziehen
etwas kompakteren Regen gibt es über
Niedersachsen und über
Nordrhein-Westfalen auch an den al ist
der Regen etwas ergiebiger und fällt
oberhalb von 1500 Metern als Schnee und
die haben wir auch morgen früh nur um
die 5 Grad an der Mildensee sind des 11
12 Grad Morgen haben wir dann am
Alpenrand Temperaturen von nur acht Grad
an der Havel sind das 17 Grad dazu ist
es morgen wieder sehr windig wie auch in
der Nacht schon mit Sturmböen an der
Nordsee und auf dem Brocken im Harz ist
es wechselnd bewölkt viele Schauer und
Gewitter sind unterwegs im Süden sind
die Wolken kompakter da gibt es auch
etwas mehr Regen am Sonntag geht es
unbeständig kühl und windig weiter erst
am Montag lassen die Regenfälle dann so
langsam nach tschüss